sombra the new character for overwatch
was officially unveiled at blizzcon and
you got the chance of player you and
Joey were also doing a live stream
yesterday yesterday where you played her
in the PTR she is live in PT our servers
for overwatch you can just go play that
now if you own the game on see and then
just set the what the service to PTR
instead of like America's or whatever
whatever your reason is yeah so I just
wanna bring you on now that you've
played or you said you played a few
matches there we watched i was watching
Joey who was really good overwatch
playing as her yesterday he's better
than you just so you know um I her
didn't everyone this heart suspicion was
that sombra was gonna be an attack
character a lot of people submission
then that rings true can you tell me
what you think about her after playing
with her uh I think she's a lot of fun I
think that she is more than just an
assault character I think she is placed
into the assault category but she's kind
of that hybrid that you were kind of
requesting for you know when we talked
about this last week she does more than
just kill people right essentially she
has a hack ability which is super useful
for multiple reasons you know you can
hack not only enemy opponents which will
leave them only with their primary like
left-click firing ability or well
console would be like whatever your
trigger button is um and their passive
so like you know Kenji can still wall
run or wall hop and stuff like a double
jump but like he can't use his like
dashing strike ability and so it
basically renders them mostly useless
right because they can't get away they
can't use your abilities and then it
lets your teammates mop them up and then
on top of that she can also hack health
packs which you know are very key
obviously to overwatch because you know
you most likely only have one or two
healers so you generally want to be able
to use health packs to heal yourself
right but she can deny the enemy the use
of health packs and on top of that by
hacking a health pack it makes that
health back come back sooner so then
your teammates get more health packs
essentially right so she's this hybrid
class in a way that's more mostly I feel
like almost the most unique character in
the game because she can play in very
different styles i guess you can kind of
play like that infiltrator harassing /
just hack
just bring so much utility to your team
why yes she does she strikes me is like
tracer mixed with a healer in a weird
like indirect way through the health
packs mixed with I don't even know like
maybe like what other character I don't
know why it's not gonna mind whether
characters like debuff like other
zenyatta does like discord but you're
not really gaining that utility
necessary and of does for her sleep dark
yeah I guess equals abilities yeah I
guess you could relate it in that way
because hacking does do kind of like
negate abilities as well as her EMP
which is her like ultimate ability which
is gonna be very useful and like gonna
be part of big combos or denials because
it's basically like okay pelusi Oh pops
his ultimate and gives everyone an over
shield and she knows that or sees that
because you know the audio keys and
whatnot and she happens to be near all
those people as long as they're within
line-of-sight she can EMP which is her
alt and it'll negate all of the shield a
line of sight I thought it was proximity
know so it's also selling I more it's
like dead I and diva like if it's there
it's like a big AoE but like if you're
behind the wall you won't get affected
by it okay yeah she it's always taught
to tell completely how she plays as a
member of team when PTR when it's like
you know 5v5 or like five zombies each
team with like a Reinhardt or something
I don't know um but it's always fun like
with a new character on and everybody i
was watching like the youtube the reveal
trailer just like her know i was
watching the kind of reading the
comments on our live stream which went
to youtube and they're like people are
asking like how would this affect that
how this fact that and people were
saying like Wilkin like junk rat put his
steel trap on her teleporter and people
are saying yeah he can so like if more
nothin knows he's doing in no sob or he
could do that um i'm a thing like
apparently if she uses the the hack the
cancel hack on Hanzo when he has one of
his unique arrows out either the sonar
or the spread it'll lock him to that
arrow he can't like switch to the other
one cuz like it I cancels out or
whatever yeah because it locks you out
from having the ability to swap it's
like the same with like another example
of that kind of situation is like Lucio
if you're in like the speed trans
version or whatever you're stuck in that
version until the hack wears off so you
can't switch to heal or if your heel you
can't switch to the speed version
yeah if you're fast enough a somber you
can also cancel junk rats chain on
someone if you throw the whatever at the
hack thing at someone else quickly you
can cancel his chain you're talking
about road hog what did I say you said
junk right oh I already said the junker
steal ya road hog sorry its chain but
it's also like if you throw it early
enough it still comes out like it
doesn't stop like it's it's a very weird
and interesting I mean again I 10pt are
there are certain things that you can
hack and certain instances that she can
hack and like stop things completely and
then sometimes it like doesn't you know
what I mean like so it just it's like a
case-by-case situation it's kind of like
what we talked about yesterday when a
lot of people were asking questions of
like what you can and can't do like you
can stop a McCree alt if he's
mid-channel like yeah but I think
apparently like the stuff that's
continuous it won't get stopped like I
think once Winston's in his rage form
you can't hack him to like unraid him or
like if soldiers got his going on
already like it doesn't stop his either
like it'll just keep going from your
time with her do you see her being more
effective as like focusing on one area
like kind of being a skirmisher a pest
or focusing just in the health pack
hacks or focusing just on you know
actually attacking do you think do you
think she would be useful as a
jack-of-all-trades throughout each match
or do you think someone really needs to
focus on one thing uh-huh it's hard to
say I mean she she does all right she
just seemed like such a complicated like
in terms of what you're thinking about
throughout each match yeah I think it's
gonna definitely depend on the the game
type I feel like right like I feel like
capture point stuff is like you
definitely want to get you know health
pack domination so to speak payload
maybe maybe not so much with the health
packs you know I mean like it's still
important but it's not as important as I
capture the point and in terms of being
a pest I feel like that's kind of what
you want to be in a way you want to try
to get to the back line and get to the
healers you know and do as much damage
to the weaker people that you can her
pass it basically makes it you know like
when I think enemy enemies are below
fifty percent you kind of see this like
infrared highlighted through like walls
is yeah almost like pseudo Widowmaker
and you want to pick those people off
because like her SMG is pretty like good
like short range but it's not gonna do
like a lot of damage so it's not like
she's going to be
killing that many people she's more like
to finish people off or like with her
hack that then allows your team to kill
those people because they don't have
like their escape abilities and whatnot
so it she's like a weird assault utility
he is kind of like a jack of all trades
in a way I guess yeah cuz I would say Oh
classifiers assault support hybrid but
again like you could just be a pure of
salt like tracer and kind of just
darting in and out if you wanted to her
damage won't be as good as tracers
though sure enter mobility because like
well because people can also read where
you're about to teleport where's tracer
you know you can go in an interaction
well I see where you were you through it
but you can leave it behind you do have
a good amount of time to like relocate
back like 15 seconds later so she's one
of those characters that has like a high
skill ceiling but like she's gonna be
very dangerous I feel like in the right
hands and very important in like even
the new quick play which is you can only
have one of each class I think I'm gonna
be important especially in the current
meta of the game yeah she's definitely
not if I was playing quickly she's not a
character I jump in as right now and
screw my team over yeah I just stick to
my career my girls area as I always do
yeah so sorry is interesting too because
if you have like saria's shield up you
can't actually hack zaria but then if
your shield is if it's not up then she
can hacking you can't use your abilities
obviously so in you know judging by that
could if sorry is shielding someone else
does that also prevent them from eating
hey if the bubble is on that person then
that person can't get hacked reinhart
where if he has a shield up you can't
hack him in front of him but if you in
vis or something get behind a Reinhardt
that you see has his shield that we can
then hack him from behind that's
interesting is at the end of that
infiltration short video they showed
zaria come in as like the bodyguard that
leader whatever or like there I don't
know if what the whole like implication
was there having Azaria go kill sombra
or something or just bodyguard the girl
yet maybe bodyguard wireless um yeah she
seems like a super interesting character
especially like I said I'd really like
those hybrid characters that's why I was
hoping for and I think people assume i
do like that you know like i like
characters like even zaria kind of you
have a few different duties with her
when you're playing you can if you're
good enough and she only people enough
you can use her for damage if you're
special if you're up close and then the
graviton started for my favorite all I'm
just going off and tangent talking about
sorry knock so let's all good somewhat
topical issues in the trailer
and you said she can cancel out the heck
if she's fast enough because no shields
don't last long but you just need to
know when the castles true cool so
obviously know when are we gonna have
her I don't yes a specific date a lot of
people have been speculating that you
know like when they did on on PTR she
kind of came out like almost like a week
or two after a nice period of time if
you kind of just think lot like
chronologically in terms of time is that
season two is going to end soon I think
season three um if I remember right
starts like early December or like end
of november and there's like instead
with this season transferring from two
to three they're shortening the gap of
how long it's going to be between
seasons whereas like 12 2 was apparent
like three weeks they're only going to
have one like a one week break this time
okay so I feel like having her come out
that week like towards that like right
when season two ends and before season
three starts is a good time because it
will give and players enough time like
oh I have a week to learn how to use
sombra or like play sombra and that'll
kind of give them prep time for season 3
yeah essentially I but I don't know I
haven't seen a specific like date mom
but definitely this year from what it
seems like so sure Pete I always just
kind of like bring up overwatch to you I
know you haven't gotten really into it
why would you keep throwing oh no this
character makes me want to play
overwatch yeah um what about her like
seems appealing or just I mean all the
characters are kind of so correct me if
I'm wrong but she has an ability where
you can throw an object and use that to
teleport to wherever it goes yeah so
basically she has like a device that you
can either set behind right-o for them
okay or you can even use it as a
mobility tool where like you can throw
it in front of you right and then like
relocate yes yeah that sounds rad but
that alone sounds super interesting to
me yeah you can do that while you're
invisible yeah well what are you going
damn yeah so any any worries about her
being okay I know you mentioned there
was a few examples where perhaps you
know a specific characters abilities
would negate some of her her advantages
but does it seem like that across the
borders a really just one or two
exceptions I mean it's really hard to
say i think everyone when they first see
her and see her toolkit like immediately
go oh my god she's okay just because of
like what she can do right but there's
even take it's like a natural
right like I and I feel like yeah it's
kind of like a given it take and I feel
like overwatch is a type of game where
it's very rock paper scissors there's
always like a hard counter right like
even yesterday when we were playing on
the PTR when somebody finally got
frustrated like I'm so sick of these
sombras they go Winston and Winston is
like such a hard counter because he's in
your face and like unless you set up one
of those devices to relocate you're not
getting away from him and you're
probably gonna die cuz you she doesn't
have like that much else she has 200
health but like she can't fight him up
close like one-on-one you know I mean
does the hacking take a little bit like
you were saying it takes like it's like
a like a two to three second channeling
and I believe if you get hit it stops
you from check yeah people are also
saying may is a good kind of person or a
constant ice stream that won't let you
even start hacking what does the
channeling of the hack or whatever stop
when you teleport yes okay yeah it
wouldn't that would be some that's some
crazy good catch it so you need to pick
and choose when you actually start the
hack or even go for it yeah if you have
a character like is if I needed another
reason to hate playing against maze may
all day I know an ebay you're good man
so I want to get you off this set right
now I'm not kidding so cool that is
sombra she's new character that we were
suspecting for a while with all the
leaks and that alternate reality thing
they were doing aughh they are not
augmented yeah so was i RG a real
alternate reality game yeah I was
getting confused augmented very
different but yeah so that's sombra
she's on PTR servers on steam to go and
play on pc right now you can really not
on steam sorry she's on PTR service
through blizzard net and you can you can
play as her right now battled uh oh yeah
I love it battle you know what I'm
saying you can go play somber on PTR
servers on battlenet battlenet whatever
you want to call it and she's not a ps4
now we don't have any word on when
she'll be there but like Eric tasted
probably right around season three is
getting ready to age yeah I speculate
cool say though awesome
you